after being on the air for nearly 30
years and more than 600 episodes there
aren't really many aspects of life that
haven't been touched upon by The
Simpsons as surreal as their animated
adventures may be from time to time life
imitates art you've lost count of the
times that bizarre storylines from
Springfield actually came true but here
are just a few occasions when the
Simpsons freakishly predicted the future
President Trump one of many episodes I
showed an ultimate reality future for
Springfield's first family but for the
future ad in the year 2000 and we learn
lisa has just been elected president of
the United States during her first
cabinet meeting President Simpson
mentioned the familiar name and you know
we've inherited quite a budget crunch
president Trump we all know how the
future turns out it's worth mentioning
that this particular episode was written
during Donald Trump's failed
presidential run in the year 2000 and
the rights of themselves the sort of
possibility of a trump presidency is the
most ridiculous thing they could imagine
for the future which can only mean that
Lisa Simpson is up next and then
president Kenya oh okay
could be worse we could be eating
Soylent which is literally named after
ground-up people from a sci-fi movie
starring Charlton Heston wait Soylent is
who while not intended to replace every
meal Soylent can replace any meal oh
yeah oh what a pretty sharable future we
live in oh you can eat in nineteen
ninety two's new kid on the block perma
seeds a TV commercial for an
all-you-can-eat seafood restaurant
called the Flying Dutchman Homer
proceeded to eat until closing time and
get kicked out while still hungry he
sues the restaurants for false
advertising but Homer and the sea
captain come to an agreement come the
bottomless peak nature's cruelest
mistake come for the Freak stay for the
pool in 2012 Phil with the wensel
wisconsin restaurant called judge plays
for its weekly Friday night fish fry
buffet
after a few trips for the restaurant and
racking up a running tab he wanted more
but the restaurant claims that one out
that's when West refused to pay we asked
for more fish and they refused to give
us any more fish the owner of chucks
plays claimed with have eaten more than
20 pieces of fish and was violating the
parfaits no sharing policy he came back
with a vengeance and he wasn't done he
came back two days later with a picket
sign with planned on picketing every day
first by early 2013
he had already moved on to other
protests but really did these sound like
the actions of a man who had all he
could eat oh it could have been me
people unknowingly ate gym mats over the
course of the series the secrets of
Springfield Elementary's lunchroom cots
cussing I've been explored again and
again but even lunch lady Doris has her
limit
we want these beef hearts and the floor
in the 1995 episode the PTA disband even
jorah subjects to using shredded
newspaper and old gym mats of
ingredients parsh shredded newspapers a
much-needed roughage and essential links
disease you didn't notice the old gym
mats there's very little meeting these
gym mats in 2014 a minor but disgusting
scandal developed when the Environmental
Working Group released a report that
found a compound called a xodar card
bottom I'd in around 500 processed food
products primarily bred including
Pillsbury dinner rolls your favorite
five-dollar footlongs
and Wonder Bread so if you've ever
wondered what put the Wonder in Wonder
Bread it's yoga mercy and in yoga it's
totally healthy the baby translator by
season 2 Houma had met his long-lost
brother herb but he leaves herb in
financial ruin after he best his whole
car manufacturing business on a
ridiculous car Homer design which was
called the Homer obviously any questions
left destitute he moves in with the
Simpsons where he creates a baby
translator that turns an infant noise
into English Mackie mm-hmm where did you
go oh there you are very amusing
the original episode added 1992 and by
the year 2004 Japanese tech and toy
company Takara developed a real-life
prototype of something very
similar after previously studying a
device that analyzes the sound of dog
barking the prototype analyzed the baby
sounds facial expressions and the body
temperature to alert parents that the
baby was hungry tired or needed to be
changed while the final product never
emerge other companies took the reins
and produce other devices to analyze the
fleshy wet loud riddles that are infants
ensuring that you'll always be able to
completely emotionally detach from your
helpless offspring yay a doughnut-shaped
universe at the end of they saved Lisa's
brain a 1999 episode in which Lisa and
her local mentor chapter attempt to rule
Springfield with their superior
intellect the smartest guy in the world
makes a cameo physicists and
cosmologists Stephen Hawking and he has
some very interesting ideas your theory
of the donut shaped universe this
intriguing / I may have to steal it well
technically the shape of a donut of the
torus and yes as it turns out the
universe may actually be shaped like the
delicious confection four years after
Homer Simpson proposed the theory
cosmologists notice radiation patterns
and space suggesting that the universe
was round and tube-like but empty in the
middle and that's not the only time
Homer see the smartest man in
Springfield oh yeah I am smart I am
smart hey there Marky I mean there may
Archie the Higgs boson while first
proposed in 1964 it wasn't until 2013
about physicists discovered the Higgs
boson the field that basically holds
atoms together in other words the
discovery helps to find the very fabric
of existence and helps to maintain how
the universe and matter work and once
again
Homer was on the cutting edge of science
in the 1998 episode The Wizard of
Evergreen Terrace
Homer attempts to become a scientist and
inventor and is seen messing around of
some formulas on a chalkboard his
meaningless math actually gets pretty
close to the actual molecular weight of
the Higgs particle which out of an
infinite possible equation is pretty
impressive but more importantly when as
we olives are going to finally catch up
with the toilet chair believe me every
man in America
would want to have one Lady gaga the
halftime show of the 2017 Super Bowl
made headlines with Lady gaga delivering
a performance that was absolutely
surreal featuring highwire stunt
pyrotechnics and the theatrical costumes
having provided her own voice for her
2012 appearance from The Simpsons Gaga
was definitely familiar with her earlier
animated performance which brought some
striking similarities to her Super Bowl
show granted Gaga's Springfield self was
only a slight exaggeration on her
normally outlandish persona Gaga why is
everyone looking at my purple hair for a
baby but this one is pretty spot-on the
Albuquerque Isotopes the 2001 episode
hungry hungry Homer it's all about Homer
going on a hunger strike to prevent the
local minor league baseball team the
Springfield isotopes from secretly
moving to Albuquerque suggestion away my
hunger pang moving my feet show my
stomach was hurt in 2002 the minor
league Calgary cannons announced to move
to Albuquerque and the local paper
published a poll asking leaders to come
up with a new name for the team
no strangers to pop culture the name
isotopes one with 67% of the vote while
the idea very clearly came from The
Simpsons isotopes is appropriate for a
team moving so close to the last Alamos
National Laboratory at least the power
plants in New Mexico can't possibly be
as bad as in Springfield right on
southern New Mexico federal officials
have confirmed but a local nuclear plant
is leaking waste in releasing radiation
into the surrounding area nope they
subject they safe isotopes thanks for
watching click salute icon to subscribe
to our youtube channel let's check out
all this cool stuff we know you're love
thing
[Music]